the Joe Rogan experience Hitler when he
went to meet Mussolini he was apparently
super exhausted so they pumped him up
with steroids and early cocaine the
cocaine they injected him with steroids
and cocaine and then he liked it so much
he asked for a second dose and they
thought it was gonna kill him and he
said give it to me and then they he went
to visit Mussolini apparently chewed
Mussolini's ear off for five hours
Mussolini was apparently thinking about
getting out of the war and Hitler talked
him out of it
just [ __ ] spit and coke talk at him
the creature came the worst thing you
can give to that guy that's a [ __ ]
Ric Flair I read a good man yeah I mean
I think they've done that to people
forever apparently that was the case
with Kennedy Kennedy they would shoot
him up with em fetta means really yeah
see if he can find that what just to
keep his energy levels up Kennedy was
very sick apparently before he died and
he had severe back pains like he was he
was really banged up and he had some
sort of a disease I don't know what the
disease was but during much of his
presidency they would put him on and
feta means to keep him active they
didn't think about the consequences of
those things back then I don't think
they truly understood addiction back
then I don't think they truly understood
look the way it affects your
decision-making process well that's back
when they used to just you know
advertise heroin in the newspaper and
stuff as a sort of in the 60s not when
was that when was that
decade was that alone they used to just
you look and you look in the papers and
they just have like such-and-such heroin
that take this sir and when they still
give women tapeworm eggs as diet pills
and yeah
those were the original diet pills right
they used to give a women a tapeworm
eggs so you ingest it and then obviously
the tapeworm grows inside of you and
eats all the food and you lose weight we
have so much to talk about what's final
Kenny first we've heard of dr. feelgood
that's who his doctor was dr. max
Jacobson was injecting him and his wife
and a list of other people I thought it
was a Motley Crue song okay dr. Jacobs
oh my god mmm
here we go what does it say here the
most scroll up a little bit the most
famous doctor patients were president
and mrs. Kennedy dr. Jacobson
visited the White House and often travel
with the Kennedys in 1961 for example he
went with the president to Vienna for a
summit meeting with Khrushchev and dr.
Jacobson said an interview gave the
president injections there in addition
to the Kennedys other persons who are
patients of the doctor included Truman
Capote Cecil B DeMille Eddie Fisher alan
jay lerner i don't know that is
representative Claude pepper of Florida
blah blah blah bunch of other
politicians brought in Tennessee
Williams Wow including included among
the number of a number of other
prominent patients of dr. Jacobson have
been a bunch of other famous people blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
an extensive inquiry also turned up the
names of well over 100 others in ranking
positions in government journalism
finance industry Society and several
entertainment fields who are said to be
patients of dr. Jacobson but who could
not be confirmed as such what does it
say about okay it cannot be said with
certainty that the Kennedys or with a
few exceptions any other specific
patient received M feta mean it is known
however that dr. Jacobson uses unusually
large amounts of amphetamine in his
practice the doctor's office reported
that dr. Jacobson buys amphetamine at
the rate of 80 grams a month that is
enough to make 100 fairly strong doses
of 25 milligrams every day hmm
so he's got a hundred people taking
hardcore doses of amphetamines every day
25 milligrams apparently they're saying
it's a big dose I don't know I mean is
it a lot okay if you just take an
adderall she was like 10 to 20 max
sometimes people that are crazy get 45
your [ __ ] grinded enamel - right to
the source
[ __ ] stomach acids get in the blood baby
well yeah I think it's been going on
forever yeah it seems like it well I
mean it's about energy right like look
at poor [ __ ] Joe Biden that poor
bastard you've been paying attention to
him a little bit he's bleeding from the
eyes yeah I saw that on TV is that I
just start bleeding yeah how old is he a
million
a million years old he's only like 78 or
some [ __ ] he's not that much older 78 is
too old to be it is too old tool if
you're that guy I mean you could be 70
like Jack LaLanne when he was 78 look
[ __ ] fantastic
when he was 9 he was pulling boats yeah
do you ever see that I don't like it
think of science ayats it is eyeball
yeah and that's too old man you know and
for evasive answers evasive answers the
guy can't see [ __ ] bleeding out of
his eyeballs that's like some Hellraiser
type [ __ ] because if you do get into
office I mean you aged it like four
times the normal rate or something
anyway well he thinks he's been in
office but that's horseshit use a vice
president especially the vice president
is probably the easiest job in the world
the Bryce vice president is like
slightly easier than hosting fear factor
that's what I think you just kind of
show up everybody else does the hard
work that [ __ ] garden that's a bear
that's barely a job
[Applause]